mosquitoes
they're a sign of summer in many parts
of the u.s they're also vectors of
pathogens spreading diseases especially
this species the 80s aegypti mosquito
it's really hard to control this
mosquito it's resistant to a lot of the
chemical insecticides which can be used
for it and there are no effective
vaccines or drugs for most of the
diseases which you can actually carry so
the florida keys mosquito control
district is turning to a novel tool
releasing millions of genetically
modified male mosquitoes designed to
reduce the population of 80s egypti
here's how it works
[Music]
it might seem strange that a tool to
combat the spread of mosquitoes relies
on the release of well more mosquitoes
the entire strategy focuses on getting
rid of female mosquitoes since they're
the only mosquitoes that bite fewer
female mosquitoes means fewer eggs which
hopefully means fewer future mosquitoes
so the ox-5034
mosquito this is what we call our
friendly male mosquito and this male
mosquito really has one job and that's
to go and find invasive female
mosquitoes mate with them and pass on to
them two genes the first genetic
modification they'll pass on to their
offspring is found in the ttav gene it's
called a self-limiting gene it stops the
development of female mosquitoes that
carry this gene so males can carry the
gene it doesn't impact them at all but
the female offspring that get the
self-limiting gene they're going to die
before they become adult female
mosquitoes the other genetic
modification these male mosquitoes will
pass on to their offspring will be a
color marker so we put the dsred2 gene
into our male mosquitoes and this is a
color marker which helps us to tell our
mosquitoes apart from the invasive wild
ones so that means that if we've
released our male mosquitoes in the
field we can look at any mosquito that
we catch and we can see whether it's one
of our mosquitoes or not the other thing
we can do is we can look at the
offspring of our male mosquitoes and if
they carry this color marker which is
visible under a microscope then you can
tell whether they've actually been
fathered by one of the male mosquitoes
it's a novel approach that specifically
targets the 80s egyptian population and
while the united states is home to more
than 200 species of mosquitoes aedes
aegypti isn't native and is according to
scientists an annoying biting pest and
the species most responsible for
transmitting dengue chikungunya yellow
fever and zika viruses to humans so
there's a lot of factors that are
involved in influencing
what makes a mosquito species such as
aes aegypti such a great vector of
viruses certainly the ability of the
virus to pass through all the
transmission barriers within the
mosquito and go from the mid gut of the
mosquito to the salivary gland so that
it can be able to transmit that virus
when we talk about the extrinsic factors
or the factors outside of the mosquito
some of the things that make aedes
aegypti such a wonderful vector of
viruses to humans is that it does live
in such close association with us this
species is known to take frequent and
multiple blood meals every time it takes
a blood meal from a human it increases
the likelihood of either being able to
pick up an infection or if it's already
infected transmitting that infection to
an uninfected person the spread of
exotic viruses by mosquitoes is a
problem in florida and around the world
oxatex technology to create a
self-limiting mosquito has been a decade
in the making so genetically modifying
any insect is challenging you have to
take the eggs of that insect put them
under a microscope and then you actually
take dna that carries these genes that
we're putting into that insect and we
insert it we inject it into those eggs
and then we wait to see if that dna
becomes part of the chromosomes that are
in that mosquito egg and then what we
can do is once it's been incorporated
into those chromosomes we can then breed
from that genetically modified mosquito
so that's what we did back in 2013 we
first injected that dna into these
mosquito eggs and then since then we've
just been breeding from that stock that
have incorporated these two genes but
along the way what we also have to do is
we have to do a lot of experiments in
the lab to see whether these genes are
functioning the way that we expect so
are they killing all the female
offspring as we expect can we see this
color marker properly and can these
mosquitoes mate effectively can they fly
properly all the kind of things you need
to check before you can go from the lab
into the field the mosquito eggs are
produced in facilities in the uk then
they're shipped to the project areas add
water and in under two weeks you'll have
about a thousand genetically modified
mosquitoes we've done this in brazil in
the past we've seen that the
neighborhoods where we released our male
mosquitoes we have more than 95
reduction in the mosquito population in
that neighborhood the release in florida
began in 2021
this year the florida keys mosquito
control district is approved to release
up to 196 million mosquitoes between
2022 and 2023 it'll be monitored by
oxitec and the mosquito control district
these type of trials they
can be
expensive to be able to really monitor
the success of these trials it's going
to require a lot of labor to be able to
document the impacts of the releases on
the multiple stages of the mosquito life
cycle or the mosquito populations and so
this is not something that is going to
be used everywhere what i can say is
that the best long-term solution for
mosquito control is going to be an
integrated mosquito management plant
that incorporates the multiple tools for
example using maybe genetically modified
mosquitoes source reduction that means
getting rid of sites around houses or
within neighborhoods that could be used
as the larval habitat and then following
up with arbicide using all these
different tools together is going to be
the best long-term solution the tools
typically used to combat mosquitoes
source reduction and insecticide will
need to adapt to the realities of a
warming world as temperatures increase
then the length of the larval stage is
going to decrease you're going to be
able to go through that life cycle
faster and you're going to end up with
more mosquitoes so certainly in these
areas that are becoming warmer it's
going to allow for species that like the
warmth like annie's egypt's eye to
increase their range and also increase
their population size
[Music]